the Virginia judge questioning the
legitimacy of the Special Counsel
investigation into former Trump campaign
chairman Paul mana Ford president Trump
seized on the news today to discredit
the entire Russia probe all we hear
about is phony Russia witch-hunt that's
all we hear speaking to the NRA in Texas
President Trump went off topic setting a
Virginia court hearing about his former
campaign chairman Paul Manafort who
faces tax fraud and money laundering
charges just when I'm walking on the
stage a highly respected judge in
Virginia made statements it says Wall
Street Journal it says judge questions
Muller's authority to prosecute
metaphore federal judge TS Ellis rebuked
special counsel Robert Muller's team
suggesting they lied about the scope of
the investigation you don't really care
about Mr Man afford to bank fraud judge
Ellis said you really care about what
information mr. Manafort can give you to
lead you to mr. Trump and an impeachment
or prosecution we're all fighting
battles but I love fighting these
battles
before heading to Texas the president
took reporters questions twice
emphasizing that no one wants to talk to
Muller more than he does I want to talk
to the people in charge if they can
prove that it's a fair situation at the
same time the president claimed the
special counsel legal team is stacked
against him the problem we have is that
you have 13 people they're all Democrats
and they're real Democrats they're angry
Democrats and that's not a fair
situation President Trump also praised
Rudy Giuliani adding the new member of
its legal team is on a learning curve
you started yesterday he'll get his
facts straight that appears to be a
reference to Giuliani's Fox interviews
where he said President Trump paid
lawyer Michael Cohen a retainer and the
money covered stormy Daniels
non-disclosure agreement funneled
through law firm and the president
repaid it oh I didn't know he did before
the president took the podium in Texas
Giuliani released a clarifying statement
first
there's no campaign violation second my
references to timing were not describing
my understanding of the president's
knowledge but instead my understanding
of these matters third it is undisputed
that the president's dismissal of former
director Comey was clearly within his
article to power throughout the day
President Trump singled out the media
after two networks incorrectly reported
Trump attorney Michael Cohen's calls
were listened to by the feds the
president urged porters to revisit
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen
Stein's memo that recommended FBI
director Comey's termination the
catalyst for the Special Counsel
appointment just read it viewers don't
know about it Rosen Stein said today the
long-awaited Inspector General's review
of the FBI Justice Department's handling
of the Clinton email should come in the
next few weeks sources close to the
matter tool Fox News the Inspector
General's team has continued to receive
and pursue new leads John some other
news late this afternoon a newly
released version of the Republican House
Intelligence Committee report with less
black ink yeah and the key thing here is
a section about former national security
adviser Mike Flynn in the unredacted
testimony you see that both
director Comey and his deputy Andrew
McCabe testified to the committee that
they did not see their agents did not
see evidence of deception when they
interviewed Michael Flynn about his
conversations with the Russian
ambassador so the question is how did
they get from that no deception to a
guilty plea for for lying with the
Special Counsel and we've got a call in
to the special counsel tonight to ask if
there was new evidence that caused them
to bring that case against Flynn based
on what we've now seen in this house
report all right keep watching that
catherine herridge thanks so much